[Musique]
pour mieux comprendre ce projet
audacieux martin bouchard président de
qsi bon soir on aimerait comprendre ce
qu'est votre projet vous dites qu'il
faut pas confondre ça avec les fermes de
serveurs qui s'installe chez nous depuis
plusieurs années on en a vu plusieurs
google à beauharnois par exemple qu'est
ce qui sera différent chez kiosque et en
fait donc les gens connaissent ni le
concept des faux nuagiques qu'on utilise
en fait tous les jours nettement nous ce
qu'on fait c'est sensiblement la même
chose mais vraiment d'utilisation dans
le traitement de l'information dont on
n'est pas dans le stockage
donc on va héberger les ordinateurs qui
vont des super ordinateurs qui vont être
en mesure d'effectuer des très grands
quelques poussées par exemple la
recherche scientifique pour des nouveaux
médicaments des vaccins l'aérospatiale à
la conduite de voitures autonomes
donc on parle vraiment de super
calculateur qui consomme énormément
d'énergie et qui dégage et le nom d'emma
chaleur et la distinction de notre
projet aussi c'est que cette chaleur est
récupérée pour être réutilisés à ce qui
concerne les calculs hautes performances
là est ce qu'il ya de la demande pour ça
ressemble à quoi le marché parce que
quand vous parlez de voitures autonomes
on comprend qu'on n'est pas encore là
mais sentez-vous déjà la demande chez
vous définitivement dans le marché les
chercheurs présentement en intelligence
artificielle on est nourri med ont rendu
une croissance de 100% aux deux fois
donc vraiment entre le québec est très
bien positionné et la plupart des
entreprises la terreur est maintenant
utilisé des supercalculateurs que ce
soit en finance en biotechnologie en néo
nazis et cherche donc des semaines
beaucoup de croissance envisagé dans le
domaine donc vos clients ne viendrait
pas que du québec si je vous comprends
bien monsieur bouchard en fait en
majeure partie ce sont des clients hors
québec parce qu'il faut comprendre que
ces gens là hors québec est très cher
leur énergie par exemple imaginer une
entreprise en asie à singapour une
entreprise en suisse qui paye son
énergie beaucoup plus cher et qui est
polluante dont vous venez ici pour faire
le plein
donc vous aussi on va offrir la
possibilité de l'entreprise d'ici mais
on pense que les entreprises
clientèle cible pour nous pour être
défenseur de ce monde et est ce monde
donc définitivement beaucoup
d'entreprises d'étrangères tu aimerais
s'établir dans nos installations
donc aujourd'hui première étape
importante on a un financement à 100%
avec des capitaux québécois qu'est-ce
que l'appui du gouvernement legault vous
apporte aujourd'hui
en fait c'est un point très important on
a tenté de créer un projet 100%
financier au québec est évidemment le
gouvernement était incontournable dans
ce sens ils ont aussi et jardins donc le
financement est vraiment bouclé dans la
zone près on ait démarré la construction
débutée donc on 995 fillon de d'attaché
pour démarrer notre projet avec
plusieurs phases effectivement votre
projet en tout là on va frôler presque
le milliard de dollars ça semble très
très ambitieux et vous êtes certain il y
aura des risques dans le parcours mais
vous êtes certains que tout ça va se
réaliser
définitivement en fait justement de
projet est scindée en phase et la fois
la défense va développer au fur et à
mesure que la demande va revenir on
prévoit environ une échelle de temps sur
certains pour le projet il faut
comprendre que c'est des installations
sont très coûteuses on parle de google a
développé un savoir plus traditionnels
autour de 7 800 millions donc on parle
de deux défauts structurels les
onéreuses cependant ça va se faire en
étape donc ça va discuter le projet pour
les investisseurs est ce qui vous
distingue vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure le fait que vous visez un campus
carbo négatif carrément et ce j'imagine
que c'est assez rare parce
qu'habituellement les centres de données
ce sont de grosses machines très très
énergivores qu'est ce qui vous distingue
spécifiquement définitivement d'hôtel
début de la conception ce projet la
récupération de l'énergie c'était
primordial pour nous donc on a développé
des concepts technologiques qui
permettent de récupérer la chaleur et de
la transporter dans notre corps on va
développer avec ça c'est la chaleur pour
alimenter les cinq pour faire pousser
exemple des fruits des légumes en plein
hiver au québec
donc contrairement aux autres centres de
données qui envoie tout c'est vraiment
la chaleur dans l'atmosphère
nous on veut réutiliser cette chaleur la
cour
amener du bien à l'associé l'insère les
tomates les petits fruits c'est vous qui
allez faire pour cécile bouchard pas
directement donc on va travailler
évidemment collaboration avec des
partenaires se lancer là dedans elle
provient on est déjà en discussion avec
plusieurs entreprises du domaine et les
discussions vont bon train on a
l'équivalent de 100 terrains de football
justin externes de type donc beaucoup de
place pour avoir plusieurs partenaires
avec nous l'a su justement québec qui
dit vouloir doubler la culture en serre
d'ici cinq ans le ministre la montagne
semble être très enthousiaste
aujourd'hui lors de la conférence de
presse est-ce qu'il se pourrait faire
des petits ce projet là définitivement
la demande est tellement importante
qu'on croit que le style de vie pour
arriver à terme prime 1 on a déjà des
terrains ailleurs au québec dont celle
où le nom et c'est possible en fait de
répliquer sur mandela à travers le
québec je crois que c'est un modèle
d'économie circulaire rentable qui
pourrait un très bon modèle pour les
québécois voulez vous faire la leçon ou
google et amazon de ce monde monsieur
bouchard avec vos installations plus
verte
la leçon peut-être pas mais je crois
qu'on essaie de créer l'exemple de
montrer la drôme puis moi je l'entends
de l'entreprise tesla les gens n'y
croyaient au début c'était nous c'est la
même chose on s'est fait dire c'est
impossible je voulais faire nous on fait
donc il n'y a pas de raison que les
jeunes ne passe pas un jour c'est une
question de volonté je pense pas qu'ils
manquent de sous pour le bon votre
entreprise mais surtout cher existe
depuis 2018 c'est tout jeune qui aime ce
qu'elle semblait déjà avoir de gros
projets de belles grandes ambitions
c'est quoi le futur pour l'entreprise
donc le futur on a quand même 8 face à
développer alors dit très confiant on
voit plusieurs sites mais c'est aussi
d'évoluer avec la technologie donc on
parle d'informatique coincé par exemple
dans nos installations entre vraiment
été développé pour s'assurer de bien
grandir avec les productions
technologique qui est toujours quelques
rapides
donc on a vraiment développé un concept
pour sûr pour se classer dans le temps
dans la prochaine décennie
bon alors on vous souhaite bonne chance
avec tous vos projets merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là c'est beaucoup
hu
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit